tj merci d'être avec nous avec plaisir à
bosser là comme en foulant la pour
terminer mon album il est presque
terminée en plus en plus je pense que je
vais le sortir 31 août 31 août après
l'été après tout après les vacances et
donc est ce que tu veux bien que le
premier invité de tmp de l'année
prochaine aller allons-y pour ces faits
je peux cautionner cet avis sera là à la
rentrée on n'a plus qu'à trouver un
deuxième invité et des chroniqueurs et
on apprend alors il va s'appeler comment
ton album
alors on n'a pas encore trouvé le
l'envié que je l'aï dit moi de quoi tu
as parlé j'ai trouvé il ya tellement de
choses est tellement de réflexion par
les trous dans cet album
chaque album je vais il m'a parlé il ya
pas mal de baladi va encore j'apprends
de ballades j'appelle ça la mairie quoi
d'autre quoi d'autre après il ya plein
de titres et un peu plus urbain barlett
balladur
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait ces soudaines